crafting the perfect story takes a
million and one rewrites crafting a
captivating ending is the hardest part
even for the best writers so we are
checking out what could have been in
some of our favorite Disney animated
movies
number One never meet your Idols May
took a flight from California where
Robert the one in four Town who speaks
Francais sat down next to May we're not
sure what they're going for in this last
storyboard image but we love it number
two who thought Panda magic could be so
complicated maze Panda would change size
based on the size of May's feelings but
this got too complicated however before
it was cut the ending would have seen
two gigantic red pandas duking it out
all across Toronto just like Godzilla vs
King Kong number three to Panda here or
to Panda over there that is the question
an early version of turning red was less
about the conflict of human vs Panda and
was more about panda May being used as a
tourist attraction to save the temple
versus her wanting to be a party Panda
at school of course this would have
changed the trajectory of the entire
movie if May's mom was okay with her
daughter being a giant red panda number
four home is where the heart is so
that's why this touching ending didn't
make it
okay
go back originally Mirabelle ran away
and was chased by abuela back into the
city they were once forced to leave the
two of them have a touching heart to
heart but only after abuela sees a mural
of her husband who sacrificed himself
along with a maxim of his to love it all
is to love entirely number five there
was once sea monsters scarier than Uncle
Ugo yes indeed the climax of Luca
included a giant Kraken for a solid sack
this didn't last because it took the
focus too far away from the lead
characters and also did the one thing
they were trying to avoid with this
movie which was showcase the deep sea
life as scary
number six what happens in the great
beyond stays in the great beyond one
ending of Soul would have seen Joe go on
to that same great beyond the end
another he would find out what happens
there and then come back to earth but
that was just too confusing number eight
we skipped one sorry number seven having
a choice was the change for Joe not what
choice he made that's why it was such a
great ending and well in this alternate
ending we got a Time skip we would jump
ahead to a year later so we could take a
peek at how Joe's life is going but
given the rest of the plot felt so
immediate this skip felt disingenuous
number eight man did Soul have a lot of
alternate endings for a movie that is so
much about choices it makes sense it
took a lot of debate to land on the
right one so in this alternate ending
Joe goes with Dorothea Williams on tour
but he wasn't just choosing his dream
over teaching he'd be teaching privately
22 being one of his students whom he
recognizes we like to imagine this is
what happens after the credits roll
number nine Raya and the repetitive
storyline namari was to be your typical
run-of-the-mill Disney villain who had
control over the Drone making the Drone
faceless villains instead of more
humanoid and stripping namari of control
over them allowed for her character to
have a Redemption Arc number 10. sisu
and the comeback kids sisu was always
fated to not make it to the end of the
movie however it was a long debate over
whether she or even the rest of the
Dragons would ever make a comeback in
one version there was never even a
possibility of the other dragons coming
back but of course this is Disney darn
it and they wanted their happy ending it
was explained what we were digging into
psychologically is if we are the
solution why are we bringing the magical
mystical creatures back in the place
where we arrived is a place that's more
connected to a more Southeast Asian and
South Asian perspective which is when we
found the solution for ourselves that we
earned the right to manifest the
mystical number 11. Bo almost did the
exact opposite of her character Beau
breaks up with Woody true story we're
glad they didn't go with that one okay
it isn't like she breaks up with him
because he's a jerk it's because she
meets a kid whom she has a special bond
with and decides to go with her and not
be lost anymore and Woody returns to
Bonnie who still loves him despite his
missing voice box number 12. Arendale is
obliterated that's right there was a
version of this story where Arendelle
Castle was washed away in a flood
everyone had to work together to rebuild
the castle in the styles of the two
groups connecting Arendelle and North
aldra through their own architectural
Styles the ending we got instead had the
Two Sisters completely separate number
13. they buried the idea of cars 4. Cruz
Ramirez Lightning McQueen's mentee was
never meant to do that final race it was
Lightning McQueen who was back on the
track competing for the title again the
film still would have ended with McQueen
mentoring Ramirez but that honestly just
didn't showcase McQueen sacrificing
anything for the win number 14. here's a
story that was completely scrapped in
the first draft of Coco the lead was an
American boy with a father from America
and a mother from Mexico but his mother
passed away so his father takes the boy
down to Mexico to meet his family for
the first time on Dia de los Muertos it
was about this boy coming to grips with
his mother being gone and saying goodbye
to her and letting go of her the
director realized that he was telling a
story that was completely antithetical
to what the day is about which is Never
Letting Go that it's about the
importance of remembering your ancestors
and keeping their memories alive while
they were telling a story that was from
a very American Western perspective
about letting go and grieving and they
realized that they needed to start Rover
number 15 the movies called Moana not
Maui originally Moana and Maui fought
taka and it was Maui who defeated her in
another rewrite the island was destroyed
and had to be pulled back up by Maui
problematically both endings gave too
much of a focus to Maui and took Moana
out of the center of the movie Women on
the creative team were not too happy
about that number 16 global warming is
real people moana's family was held
hostage in one ending how they got there
nobody knows given the entirety of
nature is out of balance though her
family is threatened anywhere in the
world number 17 we can't help but
picture an entire Army of snowgees here
the original Frozen had an awesome
alternate ending far more interesting
than Frozen 2 anyway Elsa and Anna
weren't sisters Elsa was a self-titled
evil queen with an entire Army of snow
monster Stars where the real plot and
the alternate plot merged though was
that the True Villain of the story was
Hans and Elsa instead used her Army of
snow dudes to fight the man with the
mutton chops there's a couple reasons
they decided against this ending the
first they didn't want to create what
felt like a copy of other Disney
Princess movies the second they didn't
believe the audience would get behind
Elsa's sudden Redemption Arc number 18.
Toy Story almost went International Toy
Story 3 nearly repeated Toy Story 2. it
was about Buzz malfunctioning all of the
Buzz Lightyear toys were recalled and
shipped off to Taiwan to be fixed this
is basically what the second movie was
which was void of the plot of Andy going
off to school and saying goodbye to his
toys number 19. I've got the lovely
bunch of coconuts falling in the Flames
scar was to fall into the Flames
believing that he had successfully
brought a fiery end to his nephew Simba
as well but Simba course secretly fell
into a tree while this is a bit more
disturbing and darker in tone we are
glad scar got to see he failed and had
some angry hyenas turn on him instead
number 20. Eric was nearly swimming with
the fishes yes Ursula pulled him
underwater but Sebastian dragged over
King Triton's Trident to Eric so that he
could free himself by spearing Ursula in
the chest number 21 historical events
pushed the animation studio to
completely re-face one scene originally
Stitch was going to hijack a plane named
tsunami air and fly through the middle
of a city as he was chasing gantu and
Lilo but due to the events of 9 11 one
major scene in Lilo and Stitch had to be
changed instead Stitch flew a spaceship
and the chase happened over the
mountains number 22 arventriloquist
dolls even considered children's toys
something that would have changed the
entire face of the franchise Woody like
Elsa was going to be evil pure evil not
just misunderstood with a hope for
Redemption a sneering Gunslinger whose
cruelty causes the other toys to rise up
against him and instead of having a
Charming little voice box he was a much
creepier ventriloquist doll it would
have changed literally everything now we
see where Woody's name came from number
23 the least surprising twist ever you
know how Aladdin opens up with the
merchant telling the story well he was
to be revealed as the genie at the end
of the movie note the voice of Robin
Williams and the four fingers well that
ending was cut we always knew number 24
if you want to see this alternate ending
just watch George of the Jungle 2.
Tarzan almost ended in the complete
opposite way with Tarzan and Jane
leaving nature to go to the human world
instead number 25 it was open season in
The Jungle Book Mowgli returned to the
human Village and read United with his
long-lost mother followed by a time
lapse adult Mowgli was not getting along
with nature too well and he used his
rifle on Shere Khan we can see why they
cut all that and left the movie on a
more Charming note we've got to say we
agree with pretty much all of these
changes except for maybe the ending to
Frozen two but what about you do you
wish any of these movies ended
differently let us know in the comments
and thanks for hanging out with us here
at the things